this is giant almond what's the Volt's
you're gonna do with the go he's gonna
eat the goat excellent very good deli
lamb chips I happen to be a bacon Terry
okay so this is an episode gone Jay
woman and pretty much pearl and amethyst
ah tell Stephen about this power they
can do where they can fuse into one
giant person and when you know it a
bishop comes along where they confused
into one giant person uh but they need
to get along as they need to be one and
army and stuff and they call it Oh about
the actors called opal or like the
person they create is opal I think it's
both okay
I was like I think an amalgamation of
like different minerals or something if
you ever they're different colors so I
guess it's what I don't know if you
could do with a pearl and amethyst
though I
is there a geologist in the audience I'm
like I said this is it what a pink line
I you suddenly disappeared so you said I
used to collect rocks but this may be
beyond my eye I only know of opal by how
it looks and I yeah they're very
colorful when I I think it's the
national stone of Australia interesting
tidbit but I don't know um no watch like
a million people are got like correct
you in the comments if there's like
anything wrong I that's all I know about
opal but yeah I don't know if a pearl in
an amethyst but point being a parent you
blend and become opal and in this case
it's some freakish forearmed
sixty foot tall woman that has
superpowers and is kind of badass
I thought was really awesome when maybe
she showed up I mean this shit shit get
real there let me tell you oh I love
whipping out whatever likes are the the
bow the width and the turns a bow and
arrow thing that like this super duper
arrow that like what
no fucking vultures eating my
motherfucking students uh it was it was
really bad as it actually need them even
Steven's universe there you go
I smell these ultimate cross so perfect
out the ultimate fusion
Oh sounds like Shia LeBouf so um so yeah
pretty much does the same thing to just
yells at the real people doing the work
- OH else their names that's it I love
to the background art with the trend it
had like a Chinese scroll but yeah I got
good mobile I was really cool oh the
poor girl um I mean that was a good
joking with IVA go Devon Steven get
eaten uh even the insides of that thing
are kind of cool with a little diamonds
on the organs I like I like the way I
like that amethyst style is all like
some sort of weird hip-hop breakdancing
thing and pearls like ballet yeah I love
what amethyst just grabs it as like as
loud loud smack like okay like it's so
clumsy um yeah I'm trying if there was
anything else I again so what's in it
for the beetle the beetles in a bubble
now and I'm like and and a lot of beetle
I guess yeah I kind of miss what the
press the mission was is I just find the
beetle but I guess that's like half the
bitches it's like do this but we don't
really know why yeah we just know it's
gonna end up being disappeared into
something or destroyed we don't know um
I mean the fact that they don't like
step on it or killers and they make it
disappear you know sounds like they're
sending them somewhere um but I don't
know where uh but yet the idea I think
of the fusion and they oversees all
three of them fuse no I I mean I think
this is
well in wet at the very end gun it's
like hey you can do it too and like
seems like oh and I'm like oh shit if
you could get all four of them fuck
amazing
no offense that's one of the real funs
of this possibility is life all over
that ya know you can do like anybody
with this I mean a fuck you could do
like you know this Steven along the way
that you could do like you know
coorporate the lion in there or
something like that you know like since
I mean I this make a great game I'd love
to have a side squirrel yeah and I'll
for team like in the old Simpsons Konami
game where you could like get two of
them to team up yeah um what that's kind
of I feels we put in a in a cool way
where it's like you had this idea where
they confuse this I call is like like
you said a bigger game thing that's cool
but then also like no mansis artwork to
answer this one question Steven brings
up our good questions like who shares
the same stuff they swim a great anime
like you know how like like the funny
thing about Powerpuff Girls which I
always felt that Powerpuff Girls
owed something to kind of an anime
though yeah Oh was I yeah like I'm just
like okay so it's kind of a very
stylized anime and then it's a hit here
in Japan they did their own version of
Powerpuff Girls which then at some point
I'm pretty sure mated back here and I'm
like oh my god this is like the circle
of life calling yeah I go I'm full
circle I'm like bandy and ever there was
a show that I think was tailor-made to
do something similar I'm like it's this
cuz the whole vibe of it like with these
defeating these creatures and gems and
said it reminds me of like almost like
one of those magical schoolgirl shows
are like Madoka Magica something like
that like I feel like you could totally
run with this in Japan oh the and uh
throw their own take on it so I don't
know I'd be interested to see if that
ever happens because it's got that vibe
to me with the exception of the running
time and maybe a little bit the artistic
style I mean what when it kind of be
like turning you know plant avatar last
airbender into an anime is can
it kind of already is in some respects
well um what about Powerpuff Girls well
no see Power Puff girl if I'm right now
if I watched a tell them if I'm right
they never went into like you know oh
well what are the girls feeling and what
I love is are they going through is
mostly like hey here's I think you could
probably take this my guess is if the
Japanese got a hold of this they would
turn into a 26-episode series to make it
more apply through Minh but I could see
that out of this set up well I seen
having seen one or two in the future you
know like you said she's done in them
within a Madoka kind of way yeah oh my
god having seen one or two episodes
after that like you say you saw a few
before we started watching isn't it I
did too I do know they take this idea
and they do some interesting stuff with
it which I'm glad because this is a
really like because it isn't just
refusing and making a cool design is
that these people legitimately have to
work with each other and from what I saw
they did some interesting stuff with it
we get these plot points like in the big
one here is that not only can you fuse
which they do but that Steven will be
able to do it as well see what babes are
good and Lysa it isn't just that's our
tip for the day it isn't just we can
fuse is that mentally they have to go
together to somehow they had to have
like a compromise and stuff like that so
that can lead to a lot uh you know you
can do a lot with that and honestly just
from like you know whatever you want to
call like a fan angle or a fan picture
or whatever it's like is it the
possibilities are endless with who
confuse with who is our take away when I
fuse I'm gonna mop the floor with your
fuckers faces I mean you could so easily
just do like uh I'm gonna cut you you so
easily do like just like a half and half
of like you know like one half is pearl
one half as Anna fest and they're just
this big thing is that but no they do
like they start have like four arms and
sorry
as knows but like his lips considering
how badass garnet is can you imagine her
mmm Oh pulling up with you know any of
the not only just one but the other two
or the other two plus Steven yeah it's
not way there now do you think you would
just drag the opal down oh boy that
seems kind of fresh with them on the
green little green we know they're gonna
do something where he's gonna be light
somehow the most important or like most
popular word there is an episode of
somewhere where they do kind of train I
that's another one I saw later I'll let
you know when we get there could be the
one I saw a couple episode but yeah when
I couldn't it was there was like a sort
of training program that they put him
through it was like a whole and romantic
video game kind of maybe I don't know
maybe I won I mean we'll see how we get
better uh but ya know this is a it like
I said only because we both seen one or
two future episodes it's interesting
seeing these because yeah they're
setting it up now as a kid show but you
kind of know these elements are gonna
play a bigger part in something more
adult coming on so it's interesting
watching these and be like okay well
that's the setup for this and that's the
setup for that um Steven it's up to you
which one of us lives in which is
Stevens chase okay Steven um but yeah
it's one of those things where it's like
it's cool seeing it setup but yeah
there's it's good for a kids show but
there is an impatient part of me I was
like man I won't get to like I won't get
to that stuff man cuz I know what's
coming I don't know I'm just hypnotized
so I'm fine I mean it's not that bad or
not enjoyable it's that man I know good
stuffs coming in um but yeah it's from
what I hear everyone says like all the
people comments and stuff are saying
that like the first season it's like
don't skip it but it's not like that's
not where the real good stuff is you
know it's more like just gonna hate here
some pointless event
but they're just setting up for the
other seasons are coming uh so yeah that
like you say it seems like you know uh
but boy what point like every episode is
kinda like a plot point you know like
enjoyable waste of time but it's like no
they actually are setting up something
you just don't know what it is yet so
and I survived I'm getting so I guess
there's not a time we can necessarily
talk about but at the same time it's
like it's a good set ups I mean they're
good selves to see what they're going to
do with this especially such a short
time span that they have so uh yeah a
good episode good backgrounds um
interesting idea that the fusion of the
two of them was really cool and I'm
looking forward to more that they could
do and then fun with this idea um so
yeah I'm just excited to see it both
from a psychological point of view and a
visual point of view what they can do
with it uh so yeah hopefully there's
more in the future and I'll rent it that
line and go you think the new character
here we go where and they go on it's
like I know I'm sure he's gotta come
back that's like where is he dead does
he sleep somewhere is he in that place
where they just make him disappear or
whatever where do you keep a lie in a
big pink lion my son how come he called
the goat Steven jr. before the lion you
think they'd have more of a connection
but no just this goat
so you're me you don't call a lion
Junior mmm they don't like that ah I
guess the goat is a kid uh oh my god ah
is Bob's Burgers worthy thank you